Democratic senator Elizabeth Warren who
is running for president as well has
released a plan for how to pay for
Medicare for all and we're going to go
through it and we're gonna break it down
but we do need some important context in
order to do this correctly one
controversy around Elizabeth Warren and
Medicare for all is that there's a
criticism of her that she's not really
for Medicare for all at all but that
maybe she's open to it along with lots
of other ideas which are actually the
ones that she would pursue and if that's
true then that is absolutely a concern
now lately I'm seeing her talk more and
more about how Medicare for all is the
way being more and more for it even and
supposedly leaked behind-the-scenes
private video talking to union leaders
she still was talking about how Medicare
for all she believes is the way to get
the most care to the most people the
most cheap the the the in the most
affordable way possible so that's number
one and certainly putting out a plan for
how to pay for it is a good sign that
she's taking it seriously second piece
of context there are questions
specifically around the cost of Medicare
for all that I've brought up Medicare
for all can still be the best plan I
still support Medicare for all but at
the same time if there are unanswered
questions if there are real criticisms
of it not dumb ones like the US has a
lot of people so it wouldn't work
that's a dumb criticism we've already
talked about that there are real
criticisms and on the Left we want to be
prepared to address and deal with those
now I know that there are people on the
Left who will say but David nothing on
the right ever has to be perfect and
they do it anyway so why does everything
we do have to be perfect it doesn't have
to be perfect and in fact it's not and
it may still be the best thing and the
one motor the path most worth pursuing
but we should not pretend that these
questions don't exist because we want to
be equipped to answer them so to remind
you the problems with most of the prior
plans for how to pay for Medicare for
all
are mostly twofold problem one is that
many of the plans that say here's how
much it will cost and how we pay for it
they are assuming a drastic reduction in
health care costs in the u.s. to the
levels of Australia and Canada which are
about half of
hours in order to make the numbers work
but they don't say how they would do
that they say we will do it but they
don't say how and the reality is that
the health insurance bureaucracy that we
have does add cost to the system so if
you get rid of that with a Medicare for
All system you do shave some of the cost
but only a little bit of what you would
need to shave in order to cut the price
of our health care delivery by 50% which
is what Australia and Canada have if you
can't explain how to do that the numbers
don't work that's a problem with a lot
of the plans that are out there
number two the other issue is that a lot
of the plans for Medicare for all
include these phrases that nobody in the
middle class is going to pay more in the
net but we've not seen the middle class
defined and you can get pretty slippery
with that and then lastly there's also
the question of would Elizabeth Warren
or anyone else's plan make private
insurance illegal as an industry or
would it simply say let whatever happens
to private insurance happen if people
want it okay it'll probably go up and
cost as people get out of it and that's
it and I tend to favor that I think that
it's the I think it's legally difficult
to say this industry can no longer exist
anymore so I think the as they like to
say the free market solution should be
applied if hundreds of millions of
people get out of private insurance I
think the problem will sort of solve
itself okay
so let's look at Elizabeth Warren's plan
for how to pay for Medicare for all now
as we look at this list understand that
lots of this is controversial and I'm
not going to hide that from you first of
all Warren estimates the cost at twenty
point five trillion dollars in
additional spending by the federal
government over ten years this is much
lower than what the Urban Institute
analysis says they have a very detailed
projection which says it'll cost 34
trillion additional over 10 years that
alone like if that's true if the cost is
really thirty four instead of twenty and
a half that already makes Warren's math
completely wrong now there's already
some confusion about these numbers on
the one hand she says it'll cost twenty
point five trillion but on the other
hand she's
as on our website that it's a 52
trillion dollar over 10-year plan which
is it it's sort of both and this is
confusing and it relates to the fact
that some of the existing costs paid by
consumers would instead stay in the
pockets of consumers but then there will
be new spending that has to make up for
that which is what they call additional
federal spending but the idea is either
way the baseline is 52 trillion over ten
years in one case the government is in
the middle and that's what needs to be
additionally funded now if you look at
the savings that Elizabeth Warren lists
or where she would pay for these where
the money would come from to pay for
this additional spending
she says eight point eight trillion
comes from employers instead of paying
health insurance premiums to private
insurers they start paying the
government through a payroll tax that's
eight point eight trillion two trillion
comes from taxing the investment gains
of the top one percent one trillion
comes from a wealth tax on billionaires
800 billion comes from taxes on
financial transactions and then six
point one trillion is contributed by the
states that adds up and then she also
you know is assuming drastically lower
cost which we're going to talk about in
a moment these numbers add up if you
believe the additional spending is 20
and a half trillion instead of the 34
trillion which the Urban Institute says
it will and that gets us to the
assumptions about lower prescription
drug prices and reducing administrative
spending but more importantly reducing
what we pay for healthcare period and
this is where her plan falls short this
is not unique to Elizabeth Warren she
assumes that healthcare costs will
number one drop to be much closer to
those of other countries and number two
grow much more slowly than anticipated
you have to defend those assumptions
because they are huge complicated things
and as yet she doesn't appropriately
defend them in her plan this is not me
being a Warren attacker nor a warren
shill this is me just looking at the
data and the criticisms if you look at
Elizabeth Warren's plan
on her website it is assumed as a
foregone conclusion that health care
spending drops drastically and rapidly
and almost immediately when you switch
to Medicare for all I already told you
in my general and Aleks analysis of how
to pay for Medicare for all that serious
experts even experts on the Left say
that these expectations are unrealistic
there are estimates that in the best of
cases it could take decades to tamp down
health care costs in the u.s. to make
twenty point five trillion a realistic
number a more realistic number is 34
trillion as cited by the Urban Institute
so to be completely Frank this is a fine
plan it's not drastically different than
most of the other plans that we've seen
and it's it's a problem is it counts on
drastic reductions in health care
spending that cannot be assumed unless
you explain why is the Urban Institute
and other economists that have looked at
this why are they wrong and why is
Elizabeth Warren right or why is Bernie
right about the drastic reductions in
spending because you can't attribute it
simply to changing systems simply going
from a private insurance system to
Medicare for all doesn't drop health
care spending by the 50% it would need
to drop to match that of Australia or
Canada all this being said Medicare for
all may still be the best plan even at
34 trillion in additional spending over
ten years but we've got to figure out
how to pay for that it's doable but we
just have to be honest about the numbers
and this is now the trend that the
proposals that are being put forward for
how to pay for it have extraordinarily
optimistic numbers about the cost which
serious think tanks and economists
simply don't agree with that being said
Warren being more and more behind
Medicare for all that's good but we've
got to resolve this issue because
otherwise it either will not happen even
with a Democratic president where it'll
happen and we will be shocked at how
much more it will cost which is also a
problem if we're gonna do it let's do it
right based on what it'll actually cost
we've got to deal with it at some point
in time and I hope it gets dealt with
soon